well I was going to say you you
mentioned this on stage obviously you
did the Ice House for the first time
ever yeah first time ever which it's a
legendary comedy venue it's been open 60
some odd years um but you were kind of
you gave us a peek a bit into like the
business side of your deal you get a 9
you get 90% of the door I get 90% which
I think what cuz coming from the music
world we just think of an artist they
get booked they get their money they get
their backend then they leave yes
however the show does however the show
does but you you're structuring it to
where you're ESS you're the promoter I'm
actually the promoter yep I'll put up
the money for hey the venue is going to
make their 10% and then they're going to
make their food and their liquor and all
that ex yep exactly but you're going to
be able to get your tickets I'll be able
to get my money back that I spent to put
in for
advertising um and I've always been that
way so when I see um is that pretty
common no okay most um artists feel I
think in the music industry you got to
have an agent right because the book you
inv venue but in comedy you you need
people to help you it's just that me you
you you know me and my son you know how
we move so I'm just a guy who over the
years May relationships I mean you can
call most of these club Owners at this
point oh yeah easily and and that's
exactly what I do and I book myself
years in advance like literally right
now I'm booked for the next 10 years
that's crazy that's insane I've been
like that my whole career I always
always got to know what I'm doing next
year I feel like watching you cuz I feel
like we get so much of you through
podcasts yes but I feel like you have to
have a special on Netflix or something
it's coming because I by watching you
bro like I've seen everybody live I'm a
comedy nerd so I'll go to the store and
if if one of my if a comedian's in town
that I like I'll pay and I'll go watch
you know but watching you live I was
like yo this is like as much as it's
hilarious and I'm crying out of my eyes
I like left with like I like how you you
finished but then you
said everyone hang out for another 10
minutes so I can give you guys some game
cuz you you had hit your like your your
last joke but you were like we're going
to hang out but it was very much like
kind of like a it was like it was like a
mixture of like you know life coaching
and a standup and I love and I love that
feeling and when anybody sees me that's
exactly what they take my high school
coach who loves everybody from Red Fox
down to Dave Chappelle he said he saw my
who raise you
special he said TK I've seen them all
there's nobody like you so I took the
long rout in sense um I'm a I'm doing
Netflix because of people like yourself
and let me explain to you why I have my
own network called tk. Network right and
I have my own special I don't have many
as Cat Williams but I have my own
specials did my own thing did very very
well and I'm going to I'm going to do
Netflix and I'm working on it now like
my deal with Live Nation is set up for
me to do my Netflix special and when I
do my Netflix I'm going to do something
really unique um my goal now is to um I
never did any of ice cu's movies but I
want ice CU to direct my because I start
out with NWA right I want to use baby
because he took me on the Cash Money Ru
Rider tour I want to use Dr Dre um as
one of the producers I'm going to give
all them a check because I came up
through hip-hop I didn't come up like
the Chris rocks and the um Kevin you you
were working out on stage in front of a
hip-hop crowd right I was in front of a
hip-hop crowd 20,000 30,000 in the '90s
right when we was at when hip-hop was at
the top of the game and when I do this
Netflix
special I wanted to be so unique and so
amazing that it has the same effect of
what you just said that when you leave
there or when you watch it you go what
did I just witness and I don't have to
do nothing special all I got to do is
just be me and that's what's going to
come across yeah it's crazy too cuz I
feel like uh nowadays more people are
trying to do comedy than ever because
it's so easy to get access to like I
could do a bit and it might not work if
I'm doing it at an open mic but if I
record it and I make it real out of it
with captions might work online that's
right which is happening a lot but I
feel like the the number one thing is
the same thing with music is the stage
presence you got to have your delivery
like you had a guy open for you who I
thought was okay but the host that was
hosting your show was so good and what
was different about him than the other
guy was I just felt like the presence of
like like he could have said anything I
would have laughed if that makes sense
you know what I'm saying yeah he was
hilarious delivery presence but like to
me that's kind of like for you it's like
like you command that stage man and yeah
that's and that's one thing I do know I
have I have what they call stage
presence yeah yeah I definitely have
that so I love it um coming through this
week doing the different clubs and
having everybody come out to see me was
is was a true blessing and because the
last since the last time I seen you I
have skyrocketed on the in media game
social media right this went on a whole
another level and um I just really F my
nit
and just really waking up in the morning
giving my opinion on something right no
I've seen you post like you have your
quotes and it have my quotes and man it
just really takes off but in actuality
I'm
just you know me for a while I'm just
really just being me and people find
that fascinating so I'm just going to
run with it see what it does